un sommet virtuel pour espérer trouver
des solutions durables à la crise
malienne les quinze pays de la
communauté économique des états de
l'afrique de l'ouest ont menacé de
sanctions ceux qui s'opposeraient au
plan prévu par le président ibrahim
boubacar keïta pour sortir de l'impasse
politique et économique dans laquelle se
trouve le pays
ce plan prévoit le maintien au pouvoir
du président ib cas et prône la
constitution rapide d'un gouvernement
d'union nationale ainsi que des
élections législatives partielles
le mali a aujourd'hui besoin d'une
assemblée nationale conforme aux
résultats des élections législatives
d'un gouvernement d'union nationale
d'une nouvelle cour constitutionnelle et
d'une enquête sur les événements des 10
11 et 12 juillet le président malien
sont renforcés de cette réunion les
chefs d'état ne veulent plus entendre
parler de sa démission réclamée par
l'opposition
très préoccupé par la crise politique
qui sévit au mali le conseil de sécurité
de l'onu a appelé les parties à suivre
de manière immédiate des recommandations
établies entre les pays les membres du
conseil de sécurité ont exhorté les
parties malienne à suivre ces
recommandations sans délai afin de
surmonter les tensions de donner la
priorité au dialogue et de s'abstenir de
tout acte susceptible d'alimenter les
tensions et de menacer l'état de droit
de son côté l'opposition continue de
réclamer la démission du breil boubacar
keita
rien n'a changé nous ne sommes ni
demandeurs ni preneur de ce gouvernement
d'union nationale nos positions restent
les mêmes nous réitérons notre demande
de démission du bk pour rétablir la
stabilité au mali les chefs d'état de la
cedeao ont demandé la démission
immédiate des 31 députés dont l'élection
est contestée ainsi que c'est du
président du parlement